[Music]
hallo YouTube chest lower semi friends
this is guns in here welcome to the
second episode of scotch game in this
episode we are going to deal with the
other alternative of the wide namely
Knight to c3 in the scourge game the
scots game arises after the water
efore Knight to c6 d 4e 5
Knight to f3 and after pawn captures
white took this pawn over the knight
here I recommend that you should
continue with the move Knight to f6 and
in the last episode we have gone through
the move Knight captures c6 and the move
e5 in this episode we are going to
concentrate the other popular move that
is by Knight to c3 now against this I am
recommending that you should certainly
play over here Bishop to b4 so pinning
the night thus threatening the e4 pawn
once again and that's why white options
are very much limited kinda note Bishop
to d3 is not possible because knight on
d4 ranks and move such as f3 is only
weakened white king and later on black
and easily exploited that move so
accordingly the best and the only move
which keep white in equal state that is
Knight capture c6 here we should
certainly capture with the be pawn and
now the mainline continue here with the
move Bishop to d3
apart from Bishop could be three-in-one
rapid game my opponent played Queen to
d4 where I continue with the move Queen
to e7 and I obtain a very good position
so I don't think so Queen d4 is a move
which you should consider
okay so Bishop to d3 and now certainly
black should break up the center with
the move
d5 again the mainline runs with the move
he captures defy but first we need to
see what happens if your opponent plays
the movie file well this is a very
premature attack by white and we can
punish him with the move
Knight to g4 straight away attacking
ePHI and now let me illustrate Wi-Fi is
a very bad move for example a simple
line can run like this after White
Castle and black castle black is indeed
threatening the e5 and kindly note rook
to e1 is not possible the simple reason
is after Bishop to c5 that is attacking
the weakest spot on the f2 and if white
try to defend with the move rook to e2
then after Queen to h4 black obtained of
winning advantage so other alternative
is Queen to e2 but after that you can
put a lot of pressure on the e5 pawn
with the rook to e8 then after the move
Bishop to a4 we can play f6 and now that
pawn is a simply a goner so that's why
here might should certainly capture the
d5 pawn afterwards the nature reaction
is you captured it back but instead of
that I'm recommending you should Castle
first and give white one more option to
go wrong in the database there is only
one game where a white capture the c6
pawn almost all the game went with the
castle on the Kings side but of course
we need to know what happens if you open
in place D capture c6 well after that
the line is very forceful black will
continue with the move rook check Bishop
to e3 Knight to g4 so pressurizing the
e3 Square the only good way to defend
this is Queen 12 3 but now comes a very
good move Queen to h4 so pinning the f2
and thus threatening the e3 once again
if White Castle on the Queen side there
after few exchanges let's say Knight
captures pawn captures Bishop captures
pawn captures and the move Bishop to b6
even though white is upper material no
grandmaster will prefer white position
so accordingly in one game my opponent
played the best move over here that is
g3 I responded with the move Queen to h3
and the game continued with the move
Bishop to f1
so at first sight it looks like white is
doing very good but after blacks next
reply that is Bishop captures pawn
captures and the move Queen to at six
my opponent realized that he is in a big
danger he tried to defend with the king
that is King to d2 but after Knight
captures pawn captures Bishop to g4
attacking the Queen Queen to f2 and now
Queen captures c6 I think white is
already lost in this position and just
to illustrate how quickly the game is
finished my opponent continued here with
the move Bishop to g2 I responded with
the move rook check and after the move
Queen to c1 there is a finishing blow
over here that is going to d6 Black has
so many threats and it's not easy for
the white to parry all of them the game
concluded in few moves that is rook to
be one Queen check look to b2 and after
rook to b8 my opponent simply resigned
so in practical terms after castle on
the King side nobody take on c6 but
instead they will do the castle on the
same side and now you are going to
capture back of upon now as I have
highlighted over here why it has only
few good options over here amongst them
Bishop to g5 is a mainline but we should
see what happens if your opponent plays
other move namely h3 the idea is very
simple white wants to play Queen to f3
and then later on looking forward for
the move c4 to break up black on the
Queen side well against this I'm
recommending that you should certainly
continue here with the moves asic so
supporting your center and after the
move Queen to f3 the most important move
you should take the e-file with the move
rook to e8 if Bishop to g5 then it will
transpose through the line which we are
going to see in the later stages so the
other independent move over here is
Bishop to f4 and after the move Bishop
to d6 white idea is to first of all
challenge on the e-file
so naturally we are not going to allow
this rook exchange with the move Bishop
to e6 here comes the idea that is Knight
to e2 and now c4 is definitely on the
car well pay attention over here that
this is very important move you should
continue here with the move Queen to be
it so attacking b2 no matter how white
respond for example in this game while
continue with the move b3 and now you
play Bishop to d7 the idea of black is
after Bishop exchange and the move c4 we
are going to push forward in the center
with the move d4 so we are not allowing
white to break up of a pawn structure
and after few moves such as Queen to f4
Queen captures Knight captures G Phi
hitting the knight Knight to e2 and the
move c5
black has established a passed pawn on
the D file not only that white pcs are
very much passive in this position I
have attached a sample game in the PGN
which is available in the description so
kindly go through the rest of the game
and you get a very good idea how to play
for the win in such a position one
question may occur in your mind that
what happens instead of exchanging the
bishop if you open and plays the move c4
immediately well it is not possible the
simple reason is after rook captures e -
black will simply gain two piece for a
rook which is always going to be a good
trait for the black okay let's consider
the main line that is Bishop to g5 here
black has to obviously consolidate the
center with the move c6 and now there
are three main moves in the position
amongst them Queen to f3 is the most
popular response and almost in this line
you are going to see this move often but
of course we need to know what happens
if you oppor in place other moves so the
first more I want to consider is
Knight to e2 so idea is very simple
white wants to play Knight to d4 and
then Knight will jump onto the lovely F
Phi square here black should respond
with the move at six and after the move
Bishop to h4 you should continue with
the move Bishop to d6 our plan is after
the move Knight to d4 we are going to
continue with the move c5 so attacking
the knight and now there are two options
for the white but Knight to be fire is
not a good move the simple reason is
after Bishop to be eight black will soon
kick this night with the move a six and
black obtain a nice Center with a very
good position so that's why the main
move over here is Knight to f5 in
majority of the cases whenever this
Knight arises on their fire which is a
very dangerous piece you should take it
off immediately with the move Bishop
captures f5 after Bishop captures at
first sight it looks like white obtained
a bishop pair and black has some loose
pawns on the C and D file but it is just
an illusion let me show you how first
black has to continue with the move rook
to b8 attacking b2 now there's a
important point you should know here
that is after Bishop captures f6 Queen
captures and Queen captures v5 doesn't
mean a pawn because after rook to d8
black position is far better than the
white so the natural move over here is B
3 so defending the pawn and now you
should continue with the move Bishop to
e5 attacking the rook look to see one
Queen to d6 attacking - - and here I
have two games for you if your opponent
plays h3 at this point then I have
attached a sample game in the PGN which
will give you exact idea how you should
handle such a positions so the second
alternative for the white is Bishop to
g3 well against this I'm recommending
that you should certainly capture this
bishop and after H captures you should
grab the open file with the rope enough
to eat
this is a game between two 2400 rated
player here I continue with the move
Queen to f3 which is a very natural move
idea is to pressurizing the D pawn with
the move rook to d1 no matter like
continue here with the move rook to e5
and after white challenge on the e-file
black double up on the e-file wide
exchange the one pair of the rook and
plays the obvious move c4 so far you
should have a very good idea what your
response should be yeah you are aiming
for the move d4 in this game first black
played g6 kicking the bishop and after
the move Bishop to d3 now we continue
with the move d4 which at first side
looks impossible because I can certainly
give this chair and after rook to e8
white can simply capture this pawn and
isn't black is a clear pond down well
that's true but the problem over here is
black activity on the Kings side is more
than sufficient black continue with the
move Knight to g4 initially white start
pushing his Queen side with the move
rook to even and after King to g7 he
played the move a 4 black continue here
with the move Queen to e5 so there is a
deadly threat over here so for example
if white foolishly play-fi then after
Queen to h5 white King will be
checkmated so accordingly white ride
over here Queen to d7 keeping eye on the
rock but now comes the star mu of the
game I wonder if you can spot it black
has this amazing flow Knight captures f2
boo hahaha
it's attacking the bishop so why try the
counter sacrifice that is Bishop
captures g6 but after King captures and
King captures f2 there is no surprise
that black win this game in a style
after Queen to e3 check King to have fun
and now rook to e6
is defenseless to save the maid except
he has to give the Queen which after all
not enough to save the game the second
popular move over here is Knight to a4
which more or less has same idea to play
the MU c4 so against this our plan of
campaign will remain same we are going
to play first of all at 6 and after the
move Bishop to h4 it's important to play
over here rook to e8 okay white execute
his plan with the mu c4 and now you play
the move Bishop to d6 after pawn
captures and pawn captures yes indeed
black obtained an isolated pawn but in
return black get tremendous piece
activity not to forget that D pawn is
controlling some critical squares now
just to illustrate the plan of the
campaign from the black perspective I'm
going to show you a grandmaster game
where he easily outplayed his low ranked
opponent in the game white continue with
the move rook to c1 and black responded
with the move Bishop to f4 attacking the
book white reveal his plan with the move
rook to see fire pressurizing the d5
square but black calmly played over here
Queen to d6 attacking h2 if white plays
the move Bishop to g3 then I have
attached a simple line in the PGN so
kindly go through it but in the game
white plays the obvious move that is
Bishop captures f6 and after Queen
captures grab the loose d5 pawn yes
indeed black is upon down but look at
the piece activity of the black after
the move Bishop to b7 attacking the rook
rook to c5 and now rook a to d8 pinning
the bishop so white unpin the bishop
with the move Queen to c2 and now black
plays the most critical move in the game
that is Queen to d6 attacking d3
attacking as true so what to do well
white come up with the sequence that is
Bishop check and after King to h8 he
played the moon g3 which on the surface
bury all the threat but after blacks few
responses that is Bishop to e5 white has
to save the bishop so he played the move
Bishop to f5 but after all this
transaction black obtain a decent
attacking position with the move Bishop
to b4 attacking the rook white respond
with the move rook to be for attacking
the bishop and after the move Bishop to
c6 he simply played the move rook to fi
we reach to the most important part of
the game and my question is can you spot
a move which can finish up the white
right now yes indeed there is such a
move exist in the position where in fact
white can resign the game Grandmaster
find this amazing blue rook to e3 boom
hahaha well the simple threat is
capturing the g3 pawn and delivering a
checkmate and funny enough even though I
have so many pieces there are not enough
resources to stop this the best I can do
is to capture this rook but after Bishop
captures rook to f2 black delivers the
final blow with the move in check and
game is over okay so now let's see the
most critical line in this position that
is Queen to f3 so idea is to double
attacking on f6 and asking black what
you are going to do about it
we're here Bishop to d6 is the most
accurate reply but I think most of you
opponent are prepared for that so
instead of that I'm going to recommend a
very tricky move in this position that
is at six at six contains a very good
trap in this position and the trap goes
if white plays a retrieving move that is
Bishop to h4 we're here black should
continue with the mood GFI attacking the
bishop and after the move Bishop to g3
black has this stunning reply
Bishop to g4 Callie not Queen to III not
possible the simple reason is up to d4
white he's going to lose a piece so the
only other good alternative is Bishop to
c7 attacking the Queen
but after Bishop captures Bishop
captures rook captures Bishop captures
Bishop captures night and after pawn
captures White has some horrible pawn
structure and even though material is
balanced this game can be easily won if
black plays some accurate moves so that
was an interesting trap you should have
wear of it instead of Bishop to h4 if
you open plays Bishop to f4 then it will
transpose to the h3 variation which can
be arises after the water rook to e8 so
black is threatening the move Bishop to
g4 and after the move h3 and the move
Bishop to d6 we are back into the track
of h3 variation ok finally let's see
what happens if white captured the Nile
so after Bishop captures Queen captures
Queen captures and pawn captures indeed
black get some double pawn on the King
side but because Queen has been
exchanged there is not much danger in
this position if you remove all the pcs
from the board then white might get
slight advantage but in the most of the
lines it's not going to happen and
following games will give you a very
good idea how to play for the win in
such a positions the first important
point you should notice black is having
a bishop pair and in many cases black
rook will go onto the open E and the B
file where they will get a tremendous
counter play the majority of the game
played in this line might obtain a
straightforward plan that is Knight to
e2 so white knight has some wonderful
outposts in the situation but
nevertheless black has some amazing
counter play with the move rook to b8 so
there is an x-ray on b2 either white has
to play b3 or in this game white
continue with the move rook to be won
and now you grab the open file with the
move rook to e8
okay let's see the two different
approached by the white in the first
game white played night to deform here
I'm recommending that you should defend
the c6 with the move Bishop to d7 and
now mainly to approach is done by the
right side if you open and place C 3 and
B 4 then I have attached a sample game
in the PGN so kind of go through it so
the most important move I want to
consider over here is Knight to f5
attacking at six no matter we are going
to play Bishop to f8 and now we are
going to follow one of my game against a
free day master where my opponent
continued with the MU B 3 his idea is to
free up his be rock no matter I continue
my queen side assault with the move fi
he stopped me there with the move a4 and
now I played the move H 5 H Phi has long
term prospect that is my King can get a
root in the center wire g7 at 6 and then
G Phi which we are going to see later on
in this game
my opponent played h4 and now I played
rook to be 4 so attacking edge for my
opponent responded with the moon g3 and
now rook to e5 attacking the knight he
responded with the move Knight to e3 and
I responded with the move rook to be hit
my idea was after rook to even I want to
double up the rook on the e-file with
the move rook B to e8 my opponent
offered rook exchange after Knight 2 G 2
which I happily denied after the move
Bishop to b4 attacking the rook Kiley
note rook captures Aoife is a very bad
move the simple reason is it will allow
black to straighten up spawn with a very
good advantage so in the game he decided
to play rook to have fun and now my King
March start rolling with the mu King to
g7 he responded with the move Knight to
f4 I played King to at 6 and now he
played King to g2 okay so far it is only
black who has done some progress
in the position it's time to activate
the only bad bishop in the position so I
played Bishop to g4 so my idea was to
play Bishop to d2 grabbing the Nile
giving white some double pawn and then
play Bishop to e2 with a wonderful
position my opponent saw that so he
played f3 and now I dropped my bishop
back to the d7
he continued with the move rook to f2 i
played Bishop to d6 he played Knight to
h3 then after Bishop to c5 look to her
phone and rook to e3 white is clearly in
zoogs rank state and it is not clear
what white should actually do black's
initiative continued here with the move
Bishop to d6 attacking the knight here
my opponent made a critical mistake by
playing knight 23 this allow me to play
a winning stamp with the move rook to g8
so there is a track on g3 which cannot
be easily defended the game finished
very quickly after king - f2 rook
captures d3 pawn captures and push up to
H three white position is completely
collapsing he continued here with the
move rook to Sivan I give him some
checks so after Bishop captures
came to e2 rook check King to d1 and
Bishop to a5 in the desperation of
counter play my opponent plays rook
capture c6 but I think it's a big time
mistake and I wonder if you can spot the
repetition of this move okay I hope you
find this sequence that is rook check
King to see - black has this amazing
blue Bishop captures d3 after King
captures and rook captures after the
whole sequence black is a clear piece up
you can see the rest of the moves in the
PGN the second move by Cantrell over
here is Knight to g3 but against this
I'm recommending that you should
continue with the move Bishop to c5 and
now there are two moves
white can play over here if you open and
played Knight to h5 then I have attached
a sample game in the PGA so you can
check it out but here I want to consider
the most critical move Knight to f5 I
got this position in a blitz game
against a 2100 rated player where I
continue with the move h5 and my
opponent here continue with the move b3
I played rook to e5 so this rook to e
Phi is a very good move which not only
dislodging the wonderful light but it
will also give black at the later part
to double up the roof on the e-file so
very important concept which you should
remember my opponent continued with the
move Knight waits for I responded with
the move Bishop to g4 so planning is
Bishop to e2 and rook to e8 which my
opponent allow me to execute because
after s3 I indeed play Bishop to e2 and
after.look to even I double up my rook
on the e-file so the net result is white
knight is completely off side and this
will give a gate advantage to the black
position he continued here with the MU a
4 I responded with the move fi and now
he played rogue b2 c1
I attack his rook with the move Bishop
to e3 and after rook to be even
I played Bishop to b4 forcing the issue
here why doesn't have any good choice
but it has to accept the bishop now so
after the rook captures rook captures
Bishop captures and rook captures e to
black has established a rook on the
second rank and that means it is only
black who is playing for the win the few
moves has been played in the game my
opponent played c4 where after pawn
captures pawn captures and the move rook
to a2 not only a pawn falls in the game
but later on I managed to push my own a
pawn and converting the full point
that's it guys with this 2 episode I am
definitely sure that you have gained the
confidence to play for the win and the
scotch game well thank you for watching
this video feel free to like subscribe
and comment on my video and I'll meet
you
my next episode very soon bye and take
care when your opponent plays defy and
grab more space on the queenside
well certainly here black will play
Knight to e7 you are going to learn what
you should do after your opponent plays
B cross e file well here certainly black
should capture that pawn so Knight cross
ePHI